good afternoon I'm Jason Johansen the
homicide Lieutenant with the Las Vegas
Metropolitan Police Department and I'm
here this afternoon to brief you on the
homicide investigation that we're
currently conducting at the 9800 block
of Venus Lake Court this is located in
the area of LeBaron and Fort Apache in
our Enterprise area command
earlier this morning at approximately
907 a.m officers from Enterprise area
commander dispatched to a report of a
shooting at the 9800 block of Venus Lake
Court upon arriving at the location they
found a female who was who had been shot
in the front yard of a residence that
female was transported to UMC by medical
where unfortunately she was later
pronounced deceased as a result
of her passing away homicide has
responded and we have taken over this
investigation the preliminary details we
have here are very minimum but what we
do know is that the victim arrived at
her house prior to the shooting
and that we see a male dressed in all
black clothing who is parked across the
street who then uh approaches her some
type of altercation appears to happen in
front of the house and then he returns
to the car after the shots are fired
right now we do not know what led up to
the shooting uh we don't know what the
altercation was about that is what we're
investigating at this point in time I
urge anyone with any information related
to this investigation to please reach
out to the lvmpd homicide section or
reach out to Crime Stoppers of anonymous
of Nevada I also want to point out to
Witnesses or people that live in the
area if anybody around 907 am saw any
car right now we don't have a color
we're confirming the make and model
right now but a sedan driving
erratically right around 907 a.m out in
this area there's only so many ways out
of this neighborhood to please reach out
to the homicide section or Crime
Stoppers in Nevada with that I'll take
any additional questions you may have
were there did your detectives were they
able to um did any of the houses have
security cameras do they think they
might have some some video in that
regard right now as pertain to just
about every investigation we do we're
campus in the area talking to Witnesses
and cancel the area for video that is
inside the area around nine o'clock
isn't that around the time kids go to
school and things like that were there a
lot of people out I I don't know I don't
know that information I haven't had a
chance myself to watch the video to see
who's out most of the kids I know go to
school around 8 45 so this have my 907
so
but I don't know what the local school
time is here so
thank you very much I appreciate your
time